Narcissism. It's the buzzword of a society that has become used to posting selfies on Instagram and chronicling their days on Facebook. But psychologists say narcissistic personality disorder is more than just overconfidence. It can lead to an emotionally abusive and toxic environment. In this episode, we speak with one psychologist who studies and treats people with the disorder to see if it's possible to be in a relationship with a narcissist and survive. I'm Audrey Hamilton, and this is. This is speaking of psychology. Romney Durvasila is a licensed clinical psychologist in private practice in Santa Monica, California. She's also a professor of psychology at California State University in Los Angeles, where she was named Outstanding Professor in 2012.
自恋。这是当今社会的一个流行词，人们已经习惯了在Instagram上发布自拍，在Facebook上记录生活。但心理学家表示，自恋型人格障碍不仅仅是过度自信。它可能导致一种情感虐待和有毒的环境。在本期节目中，我们采访了一位研究并治疗该障碍患者的心理学家，看看是否有可能与自恋者建立关系并生存下来。我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿，这是《心理学谈话》。罗姆尼·杜尔瓦西拉是加利福尼亚州圣莫尼卡的一位执业临床心理学家。她也是洛杉矶加州州立大学的心理学教授，并于2012年被评为杰出教授。
She has been an active member of APA committees, including the Committee on Psychology and AIDS, and was vice chair of the Committee on Women in Psychology. Most recently, she has written a book, Should I Stay or Should I Go, Surviving a Religious, relationship with a narcissist. Welcome, Dr. Romney. Thank you so much for having you. I think a lot of our listeners can relate to being involved in a bad or a toxic relationship, but your book sort of touches on something that surprised me. How do we or should we stay in these relationships? And you know, that seems sort of counterintuitive. I think most people would say if you're in a relationship with someone who is bad for you, you should leave, but you're saying that's not always possible, correct? When I called this book, should I stay or should I go, it would have been so.
她是美国心理学会（APA）委员会的活跃成员，包括心理学与艾滋病委员会，并曾担任女性心理学委员会的副主席。最近，她写了一本书《我该留下还是离开：在与自恋者的关系中生存》。欢迎你，罗姆尼博士。非常感谢你的邀请。我想我们的很多听众都能体会到陷入一段糟糕或有毒关系的感觉，但你的书触及了一些让我惊讶的事情。我们如何或者是否应该留在这些关系中？你知道，这似乎有点违反直觉。我想大多数人会说，如果你和对你不利的人在一起，你应该离开，但你说这并不总是可能的，对吗？当我给这本书起名为《我该留下还是离开》时，这本来会非常……
easy to just call it go. But the fact of the matter is that relationships aren't that simple, are they? And that I felt as a psychologist I really had to look at it through that compassion and realistic lens that people stay in relationships for lots of reasons. Money, security, fear of being alone, culture, religion, children. I mean, the list goes on and they're all very valid and very important reasons. So while a person is in a toxic relationship and doesn't feel at that point that they can leave, I didn't feel like this. then they should remain a human sacrifice or stay in something that was truly a lost cause, but to really give them honest and actionable solutions for how they might be able to stay in,
容易直接叫它《离开》。但事实是，人际关系并没有那么简单，不是吗？作为一名心理学家，我觉得我必须以一种同情和现实的眼光来看待它，人们留在一段关系中有很多原因。金钱、安全感、害怕孤独、文化、宗教、孩子。我的意思是，名单还在继续，它们都是非常正当且非常重要的理由。所以，当一个人处于一段有毒的关系中，并且觉得在那一刻无法离开时，我不觉得他们就应该成为人类牺牲品，或者留在一段注定失败的关系中，而是要给他们提供诚实且可行的解决方案，让他们知道如何能够留在……
honestly, what is a toxic solution without turning themselves into a human sacrifice? Now, the psychological term narcissism does get thrown around quite a bit as a sort of a catch-all term for someone who is self-involved or overconfident in themselves. You know, those people who post selfies constantly on Facebook or Instagram, What exactly is narcissism, though, and how can you recognize it in someone or even yourself? Narcissism is very much sort of the buzzword of our time, and it is woefully misunderstood. Narcissism is very much viewed as a disorder of sort of inflated self-esteem and grandiosity. It is those things, but in fact it's a disorder of self-esteem.
老实说，什么是“有毒”的解决方案，而不把自己变成人类牺牲品？现在，“自恋”这个心理学术语确实被广泛使用，作为一种包罗万象的词，用来形容那些以自我为中心或过度自信的人。你知道，那些在Facebook或Instagram上不断发布自拍的人。然而，自恋到底是什么？你如何在别人甚至自己身上识别它？自恋确实是我们这个时代的流行词，而且它被严重误解了。自恋在很大程度上被视为一种自尊心膨胀和自负的障碍。它确实包含这些方面，但实际上，它是一种自尊障碍。
People with narcissism are often the most insecure people in the room. and they've established a way of showing themselves as anything but that they often look like the most confident person in the room, but there's an emptiness there. I often say that there are sort of four pillars to narcissism. Lack of empathy, grandiosity, a chronic sense of entitlement, and a chronic need to seek out admiration from other people and invalidation from other people. Those really create the core of that disorder. And then that's coupled with the sort of sort of inability to regulate self-esteem, that sense of always peddling faster to get the regard of other people, and has even been viewed very much as a disorder of attachment, that inability to
自恋者往往是房间里最缺乏安全感的人。他们建立了一种方式来展示自己，表现得一点也不像那样。他们看起来往往是房间里最自信的人，但内心却空虚。我常说自恋有四个支柱：缺乏同理心、自负、长期的权利感，以及长期寻求他人赞美和认可的需求。这些构成了该障碍的核心。再加上那种无法调节自尊的能力，那种为了获得他人尊重而不断“加速”的感觉，它甚至被视为一种依恋障碍，即无法……
make deep, intimate, connected, empathic ties with another human being. When you're with someone who's narcissistic, it can often throw you off because initially, because they're so good at putting on that admiration-seeking show, they can be charismatic, often quite smart, charming, and very gripping. But over time, all of that superficial facade is met behind with a real lack of empathy, often a lack of compassion. They often don't listen very well. They'll be prone to patterns like deceit and lying. It's not the stuff that is good for very connected relationships. And the fact is, the impacts of narcissism aren't just in the intimate relationship. We see them in any critical relationships, narcissistic parents, narcissistic children, siblings, friends,
与另一个人建立深层、亲密、紧密、有同理心的联系。当你和一个自恋者在一起时，这往往会让你感到困惑，因为起初，由于他们非常擅长展示那种寻求赞美的表演，他们可能很有魅力，通常相当聪明、迷人且非常吸引人。但随着时间的推移，所有这些肤浅的伪装背后，是真正的缺乏同理心，通常也缺乏怜悯心。他们往往不善于倾听。他们容易出现欺骗和撒谎的模式。这些对建立良好的关系并无益处。事实上，自恋的影响不仅仅存在于亲密关系中。我们在任何关键关系中都能看到它们：自恋的父母、自恋的孩子、兄弟姐妹、朋友……
coworkers, and bosses. It behaves the same in all of those situations, but more than anything, it often feels like we're not being heard, we're not being noticed, and in fact, we're often being criticized and rejected on a chronic day-after-day way. The tough thing about a relationship with a narcissist is that they often run on hope. Most people, especially in an intimate relationship, with a narcissist, these relationships run on the hope of a someday better. I always call it the Beauty and the Beast piece of this. Because what did Beauty do? She just sort of danced around and loved the beast.
同事和老板。它在所有这些情况下的表现都是一样的，但最重要的是，它往往让我们觉得没有被倾听，没有被关注，事实上，我们经常在日复一日地被批评和拒绝。与自恋者建立关系的难点在于，他们往往靠“希望”维持。大多数人，特别是在与自恋者的亲密关系中，这些关系靠着“未来会更好”的希望维持。我总是称之为“美女与野兽”的部分。因为美女做了什么？她只是跳舞并爱着野兽。
The one day he went from being a raging beast to a prince. A lot of people have taken that fairy tale and they have injected it into their lives saying, if I love him enough, if I dance around enough, if I'm sweet enough, if I'm pretty enough, if I'm this enough, if I'm that enough, then I will please him and he will go from being a raging beast to a prince. It is never going to be enough. And I think that's the real paradox in the narcissistic relationship. So then the bigger question becomes, what do you do? If you're never going to be enough, one thing you need to do is stop exhausting yourself to try to be so.
有一天，他从狂暴的野兽变成了王子。很多人把那个童话故事注入到他们的生活中，说：如果我足够爱他，如果我跳舞跳得足够多，如果我足够甜美，如果我足够漂亮，如果我足够这样，如果我足够那样，那么我就会取悦他，他就会从狂暴的野兽变成王子。这永远不会足够。我认为这就是自恋关系中真正的悖论。那么更大的问题就变成了：你该怎么办？如果你永远无法做到“足够”，你需要做的第一件事就是停止为了尝试做到“足够”而耗尽自己。
Every human being in the world comes into this world more than enough and exits this world more than enough. So that's got to be the central premise. The key then becomes managing your expectations. Nothing is ever going to be enough for the narcissist. And so it's really to be your best version of yourself for yourself, for your meaning, for your purpose, to live in line with that. If it works for that person, great. If it doesn't, you're never going to be the one to please them anyhow.
世界上每个人来到这个世界时都已足够好，离开这个世界时也已足够好。所以这必须是核心前提。关键在于管理你的期望。对于自恋者来说，没有什么能让他们满足。所以，真正要做的是为了你自己、为了你的意义、为了你的目标，活出最好的自己。如果这对那个人有效，很好。如果无效，无论如何你永远不会是那个能取悦他们的人。
That's a really difficult thing to ask people to do because, again, managing expectations often does mean giving up hope. I think it's more like a re-rendering of hope. It's rewriting that hope in a way that's less about trying to run around and search. and trying to please one person, but really embedding it in your larger vision and being, again, a compassionate person yourself. And for many people to hear that, this is all about a hope of a someday that's never going to come, rather than making them feel more hopeless, for many of them, they say, I now feel like I'm living in less futility. Thank you. And I can manage my expectations.
要求人们这样做是非常困难的，因为再次强调，管理期望往往意味着放弃希望。我认为这更像是一种对希望的重新诠释。它是以一种不那么试图四处奔波、搜索并试图取悦一个人的方式重写希望，而是真正将其融入你更宏大的愿景和存在中，并再次成为一个有同情心的人。对于许多听到这一点的人来说，这完全是关于一个永远不会到来的“某一天”的希望，而不是让他们感到更绝望，对他们中的许多人来说，他们说：“我现在觉得我生活得没那么徒劳了。”谢谢。我可以管理我的期望。
And in line with managing those expectations comes the need to make sure that you build up supportive networks around you. So if you have that partner that doesn't listen, if you have that boss that's sabotaging you, if you have that friend who is chronically not compassionate, when you have something good happen to you or something you want a sounding board for, don't take it to them. Take it to those people in your world, your stakeholders who are good listeners, who are your cheerleaders, who do support you. So many people exhaust themselves in the process of trying to please the unpleasible narcissist. They forget all of the great listeners and all of the compassionate, empathic people they already have in their lives. Have you ever treated a narcissist?
在管理这些期望的同时，还需要确保你在周围建立支持网络。所以，如果你有一个不听你说话的伴侣，如果你有一个破坏你的老板，如果你有一个长期缺乏同情心的朋友，当你发生好事或需要倾诉对象时，不要去找他们。去找你世界里的那些人，那些好的倾听者，那些为你加油的人，那些真正支持你的人。许多人在试图取悦无法取悦的自恋者的过程中耗尽了自己。他们忘记了生活中已经拥有的所有优秀的倾听者和所有富有同情心、有同理心的人。你治疗过自恋者吗？
Are they treatable or even open to being treated? The question of whether a narcissist is treatable is a very controversial area in psychology. I've got my take on it and I know others are not in agreement and I respectfully hear their stand on it too. I have worked with several clients with narcissistic personality disorder, pathological narcissism, and strong narcissistic traits. I often view it like a glacier moving. Glaciers do move. It's just pretty small. And where we often have some of our greatest success with narcissistic clients is in changing behaviors.
他们可以被治疗吗，或者甚至愿意接受治疗吗？自恋者是否可以治疗是心理学中一个非常有争议的领域。我有我的看法，我知道其他人并不认同，我也尊重他们的立场。我曾与几位患有自恋型人格障碍、病理性自恋和强烈自恋特质的客户合作过。我常把它比作冰川移动。冰川确实在移动。只是非常缓慢。我们在自恋客户身上取得最大成功的地方往往是在改变行为方面。
So, for example, a behavior may be chronically being late, which really is a show of disrespect and a lack of empathy that you would make someone wait and not communicate with them. And so we might be able to do through a variety of behavioral strategies. teach that narcissist that this is disrespectful, that it is important to show up on time. The problem is now they're showing on time and they're still not empathic. Teaching empathy in an adult is a much taller order, though there are many in the field that will say that the process of psychotherapy and the attachment that can be created between therapist and client can, in some cases,
例如，一种行为可能是长期迟到，这实际上表现出一种不尊重和缺乏同理心，因为你会让别人等待而不与他们沟通。因此，我们可能通过各种行为策略，教导那个自恋者这是不尊重的，准时到达很重要。问题是，现在他们准时出现了，但仍然没有同理心。教导成年人同理心是一项艰巨得多的任务，尽管领域内有许多人会说，心理治疗的过程以及在治疗师和客户之间建立的依恋关系，在某些情况下……
if the narcissistic client is motivated and has enough insight, can create some movement where you can actually see some significant, change. It's a relatively unlikely scenario because the key here is the insight that the narcissist has to be motivated to change. And often they have to hit rock bottom before they see a need for that change. For example, a spouse leaving with the children, losing a job, losing their money, losing their home. There often needs to be some big slaps in the face. And I'm a psychologist, in many ways we are in the business of hope. And I believe every human being, regardless of what they bring into a therapy room or into any human interaction deserves the best of us,
如果自恋的客户有动力并有足够的洞察力，可以创造一些改变，让你确实能看到一些显著的变化。这是一种相对不太可能的情况，因为这里的关键是自恋者必须有改变的动力。通常他们必须跌入谷底才能看到改变的必要性。例如，配偶带着孩子离开、失业、失去金钱、失去家园。通常需要一些沉重的打击。我是一名心理学家，在很多方面我们从事的是希望的事业。我相信每个人，无论他们带入治疗室或任何人类互动中带来什么，都值得我们最好的……
our compassion, our empathy. And that's how I would operate in therapy when I do it. But I have to say that the changes I see are glacial and the people who most often suffer, even though we may be doing good work in therapy, they'll often very quickly go back to their old habits when they're in their relationships. I think there's a lot of blame being put on technology and the rise of social media for a shift in how couples meet and communities. How do you know when social media is working against you in your quest for finding the right person and when it's beneficial?
我们的同情心，我们的同理心。这就是我在进行治疗时的操作方式。但我必须说，我看到的改变是缓慢的，而那些最常受苦的人，即使我们在治疗中做得很好，当他们回到人际关系中时，往往会很快回到他们的旧习惯。我认为人们把很多责任归咎于技术和社交媒体的兴起，认为这改变了情侣见面和社区的方式。你如何知道社交媒体何时在你的寻找合适伴侣的过程中起反作用，何时又是有益的？
Social media is here to stay, and as much as I could sit here as a psychologist and say, it is the root of all that is evil, it's here, and it's a new language in which we communicate. What it is not, though, is a stand-in for true human contact. We human beings are wired to like other three-dimensional human beings in our world. When social media is becoming a substitute or a go-to for face-to-face interaction with people, I do think then it's impeding the ability for a person to really build a three-dimensional relationship, one that is full of empathy, respect, mutuality, the back and forth that makes a long-term relationship. Social media is making it very efficient to get to know people from all over the world. You may actually have somebody you have three times daily contact with in Italy or Scotland or something like that. That was once not possible.
社交媒体已经存在，尽管我可以作为心理学家坐在这里说，它是万恶之源，但它就在这里，这是我们交流的一种新语言。然而，它并不是真正人类接触的替代品。我们人类天生喜欢我们世界里的其他三维人类。当社交媒体成为面对面交流的替代品或首选时，我确实认为它阻碍了一个人真正建立三维关系的能力，那种充满同理心、尊重、互惠、使长期关系得以维持的互动。社交媒体使得结识世界各地的人变得非常高效。你可能确实有一个每天联系三次的人在意大利或苏格兰之类的地方。这在过去是不可能的。
But it cannot be your sole go-to. And I think I caution people, particularly young people, that this cannot be your only place to play. And while apps like Tinder can be a lot of fun, right swiping is probably not sufficient depth to create a relationship with somebody who's going to be your life partner with whom you make a lot of fun. right swiping is probably not sufficient depth to create a relationship with somebody who's going to be your life partner with whom you may grow old and raise children. So it's to view it as a tool, but one of many tools to facilitate the ability to meet another human being. The other thing that social media raises in terms of relationships is it definitely turns up the dial on superficiality in relationships. Social media is very visual. There's a lot on sort of what a person does and how a person looks.
但它不能成为你唯一的选择。我认为我提醒人们，特别是年轻人，这不能成为你唯一的游乐场。虽然像Tinder这样的应用程序可能很有趣，但向右滑动可能不足以建立一段关系，与一个将成为你生活伴侣的人，与他一起……向右滑动可能不足以建立一段关系，与一个将成为你生活伴侣的人，与他一起变老并抚养孩子。所以要把它视为一种工具，但它是促进结识他人能力的众多工具之一。社交媒体在人际关系方面提出的另一件事是，它绝对调高了人际关系中的肤浅程度。社交媒体非常视觉化。关于一个人做什么以及一个人看起来如何的内容很多。
And young people are very vulnerable to that. So one of the real challenges is that as social media and technology and our various devices sort of threaten to make human relationships more superficial and sort of empty them of the kind of depth they need, it does require all of us, parents, people getting into relationships, teachers, and young people, to remain aware of the fact that we are. are becoming more superficial in the face of sort of these visual worlds. And to really be aware that many times of people who are doing best in those worlds who are sort of having the most success sometimes do run towards a superficial.
年轻人对此非常脆弱。因此，真正的挑战之一是，随着社交媒体、技术和我们的各种设备威胁要使人际关系变得更加肤浅，并掏空它们所需的深度，这确实需要我们所有人——父母、进入关系的人、老师和年轻人——保持清醒的认识，意识到我们正在面对这些视觉世界时变得更加肤浅。并真正意识到，很多时候在这些世界中表现最好、取得最大成功的人，有时确实倾向于肤浅。
That's a lot of fun in the courtship phase and that's a lot of fun from a flash in the pan place, but it often doesn't have legs to go the distance. Mindfulness may in fact be the single most important tool in a relationship and it is so easy because it's really retaining that awareness of what is probably one of your most important human interactions in your life. It is about taking that extra moment, that extra pause, being aware of, plugging in and tuning into the world of your partner, the needs of your partner, the aspirations of your partner, and then for both of you to do that together. in a distracted world where we can get emails 24-7, where we're getting pings and dings, and we're constantly being pulled at. Mindfulness really requires now a very different kind of discipline. It really means you have to be on your game and make a conscious effort to say, I just walked in the
这在求爱阶段很有趣，在昙花一现的地方也很有趣，但它往往没有长久发展的潜力。正念可能实际上是人际关系中最重要的工具，而且它很容易做到，因为它实际上是保持对你生活中可能最重要的人际互动之一的觉知。它是关于多花一点时间，多一点停顿，意识到这一点，投入并调频进入你伴侣的世界、伴侣的需求、伴侣的愿望，然后你们俩一起这样做。在一个分心的世界里，我们可以24小时全天候收到电子邮件，我们不断收到提示音，我们不断被拉扯。正念现在确实需要一种非常不同的纪律。它确实意味着你必须保持专注，并做出有意识的努力说：我刚走进……
door and I am going to put this down and go attend to this very important person rather than to sort of let that sort of email demon follow you right through the front door. It is so easy to forget about the living, breathing people in our lives when there's something in our pocket vibrating 24-7. Well, Dr. Romney, this has been very interesting. Thank you so much for joining us. Thank you so much for having it. It was really, really interesting. Thanks for listening.
门口，我要放下这个，去照顾这个非常重要的人，而不是让那种电子邮件恶魔跟着你穿过前门。当我们的口袋里有东西24小时全天候振动时，很容易忘记我们生活中活生生的人。好吧，罗姆尼博士，这非常有趣。非常感谢你的加入。非常感谢你的邀请。这真的非常非常有趣。感谢收听。
To hear more episodes, please go to our website at speakingofpsychology.org. With the American Psychological Association Speaking of Psychology, I'm Audrey Hamilton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
要收听更多剧集，请访问我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org。我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿，这是美国心理学会的《心理学谈话》。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。